hello everyone it's seven o'clock world
leaders are meeting in brussels this
morning for an extraordinary nato summit
exactly one month on from russia's
invasion of ukraine the prime minister
boris johnson will promise to rush an
extra six thousand missiles to ukraine
and is calling on other western nations
to step up their support u.s president
joe biden's expected to use the summit
to announce new sanctions against russia
we'll be live in brussels throughout the
morning
and in the next few minutes we'll be
speaking to the chancellor rishi sunak
about the uk's support for ukraine and
about how britons are facing the biggest
fall in living standards on record
it is thursday the 24th of march
well in the last few minutes nato's
secretary general has said that vladimir
putin has made a big mistake and there
is a new sense of urgency about europe's
defense
it's all eyes on brussels where nato
leaders are meeting to discuss the
ukraine crisis including how they'll
respond if russia uses chemical weapons
as the war enters its second month
president zielenski calls for global
protests in support of ukraine
calculate all possible outcomes one of
russia's most senior diplomats tells sky
news that moscow could press the nuclear
button if nato provokes them
if russia is provoked by nato if russia
is attacked by nato i don't know
so we are we are nuclear power
why not
also ahead what the chancellor's spring
statement means to you with the overall
tax burden predicted to rise to the
highest level since the 1940s
prince william expresses his profound
sorrow for slavery but stopped short of
the apology demanded by activists in
jamaica
also this morning
[Music]
[Music]
we'll be talking about the afghan girls
banned by the taliban from going to
school
and as europe faces its biggest refugee
crisis since the second world war we'll
be speaking to the director of a new
film about how hard it can be crossing
borders
[Music]
good morning case away this week you've
got me instead it is exactly one month
since russia invaded ukraine world
leaders are gathering in brussels this
morning for an extraordinary nato summit
on the crisis
well russia has taken just one major
city curse on but they have reduced
others to rubble killing thousands of
people and causing millions to flee for
their lives let's look at the latest
developments
well in his latest address president
zielinski called for global protests to
demand an end to russia's invasion
he also called for nato to provide
effective and unrestricted support to
ukraine as the uk promised to send
another six thousand anti-tank missiles
nato estimates that seven to fifteen
thousand russian troops have been killed
in the past month by comparison
15 000 russians died in a decade in
afghanistan
u.s intelligence suggests russian
advances towards kiev city center have
stopped and russia is now setting up
defensive positions around 10 miles away
well in the last few minutes we've heard
from the native secretary general jen
stoltenberg he said that there was a new
sense of urgency about europe's defense
president putin has made a big mistake
and that is to launch a war to wage war
against an independent sovereign nation
he has
underestimated the strength of the
ukrainian people the bravery of the
ukrainian people and the armed forces
and and therefore they also
meet
and they expected
we need in a way to address
the actions that we see russia is doing
in ukraine and that's also the reason
why we have significantly stepped up the
support to ukraine and why we have
increased the
presence of nato troops in the eastern
part of the alliance and increased the
readiness of troops
we do so to be able to respond and uh
and address any threat any challenge to
our security and
what kind of decisions and what kind of
the decisions they may make in moscow
not speculate further about that
well our security and defense
editor deborah haynes is in brussels for
us and deborah what pressure can they
put on russia today
well we have already put on a huge
amount of pressure in terms of their
response bolstering the number of nato
troops along east
nato's eastern flank um but what we're
going to be hearing today is about a
further increasing of the number of nato
forces
along the eastern side of the alliance
and also long-term plans it's clear that
deterrence has failed in this instance
despite all the warnings from nato
leaders not to invade ukraine president
putin still went ahead and invaded and
so for the alliance which sees this as
the gravest security crisis since the
second world war we're going to have to
see a huge change in the way that they
handle their defenses how much they
invest in their defenses and their
ability to use military strength take
risk and one other key issue that
everyone's going to be looking for is
how nato is going to be signaling to
russia of the consequences that russia
would face should it use unconventional
weapons outlawed weapons chemical
weapons nuclear weapons in the ukraine
conflict yen stoltenberg the secretary
general was just asked a few minutes ago
whether if a chemical weapons attack was
launched in ukraine but actually the
effect of those chemicals impacted nato
member states across the border would
that be considered as an article 5
attack remember article 5 is when an
attack on one
nato member state uh prompts a response
by the entire alliance he didn't give a
definitive answer on that point but it's
clearly something that's on people's
minds how will nato respond should the
conflict in ukraine escalate to this new
kind of unconventional weapons being
used that's something that we'll look
out for
okay deborah thanks very much
well here in the uk the government's
fiscal watchdog says the britons are
facing the highest tax burden since the
1940s and the biggest drop in living
standards
since records began well i'm joined now
by the chancellor rishi sunak good to
talk to you this morning chancellor you
are obviously keen to be seen as the tax
reducing chancellor but do you accept
that the tax burden is now up
yes well good morning i think first of
all to put it in context you have to
remember i was also the chancellor who
had to
oversee what happened during the
pandemic that's the first time that's
happened in through 100 years we had the
biggest economic shock in 300 years and
borrowings spiraled up to levels we
haven't seen since world war ii i had to
introduce things like furlough so that's
the context for all the actions that
i've had to take but i know families are
struggling right now with the cost of
living which is why yesterday i
announced a tax plan which delivers the
biggest net cut in personal taxes in
over a quarter of a century cutting fuel
duty five pence a liter raising national
insurance thresholds giving 30 million
workers a tax saving with typical
workers saving 330 pounds and cutting
income tax for the first time in 16
years putting more money in people's
pockets so whilst i can't solve every
problem and i've always been honest with
people about that well i can make a
difference of course that's what i want
to do and i think the plan that we
announced yesterday will do exactly that
and support hard-working british
families but but are you being honest
you know when you're talking about tax
cuts but the fact is that the overall
burden of taxes is going to reach the
highest level since the late 1940s in
the next couple of years taxes are going
to be higher than they have ever been
and that and that is a reflection of two
things first and foremost the fact that
we've experienced as i said a pandemic
that was a pretty exceptional episode in
our country's history borrowing spiraled
up to levels we haven't seen this since
the second world war biggest economic
shock in three over 300 years um
and had to introduce interventions like
furlough i think most people will
understand that an exceptional
experience like that probably does lead
to an exceptional response and that's
what we're now grappling with the
aftermath of kovid but also we are
continuing to invest in public services
and i think you know that's what your
viewers and people want us to to be able
to do as well particularly and most
importantly the nhs and social care
getting on with tackling the backlog
there pulling more police officers on
the street putting more money into our
classrooms those are all the things the
government is doing we're seeing very
strong investment in public services
over this parliament
and that of course needs to be paid for
but but there are those who will say
that what you did yesterday didn't go
far enough and didn't actually help the
very poorest in society there's no
increase in universal credit there's no
increase in pensions no increase in
disability benefit
the very poorest in society do not earn
enough to benefit from the announcements
that you made yesterday do they they are
not going to benefit from an increased
national insurance
threshold or a one percent tax cut
because they just simply don't earn
enough and for those people there was
nothing yesterday
well they actually are my priority which
is why we started our action to help
them in the autumn in my autumn budget
we made the operation of universal
credit more generous so that people can
keep more of what they earn especially
those people that you're talking about
on low incomes they will also benefit
and that what we did then was a 2
billion pound tax cut for about 2
million low earners they will also
disproportionately benefit from the
significant increase in the national
living wage that's just about to come in
it's going to go up six point six
percent now the combination of all these
things means that for example let's take
a single mother with two children
renting working full time on the
national living wage so a low earner as
you described that that mother is going
to be
1600 pounds a year better off as a
result of all these decisions and it's
right that we are focusing attention on
them but i do believe the policies that
we're putting in place will help those
people on low incomes disproportionately
in fact that's what you believe but but
it's not what other people who've
examined what you've you've set out
yesterday believe you know the
resolution foundation says that
two-thirds of the benefits you announced
yesterday will will help only the top 50
tax cuts for middle and top earners only
one and three of the pounds that is
going to be saved goes to the least well
off and you look at what you've
you've really flagged up to us
today about fuel duty going down five
pence a liter that only helps if you've
got a car a third of the population
don't have access to a car um it it just
seems to add to the to the feeling that
maybe you're not really in touch with
the hard reality of lots of people's
lives
actually when i go out about talking to
people fuel duty is one of the things
that is raised most often with me
because the vast majority of people in
this country do use their cars to get
around particularly those in rural areas
particularly those on lower incomes for
whom petrol bills are are a much larger
part of their income so this is
something actually reviewed we've got a
lovely picture of what happened
if i could just finish if i could just
finish on to the finish answering the
question and and actually talking to the
person who was doing that with it you
know they use their car every day to get
to work they notice obviously petrol
prices going up you know they were
appreciative of the fact that we're
cutting fuel duty and it does
demonstrate we're on the side of people
accepting that we can't solve every
problem or fully fully make up for some
of the increase in petrol prices but
with regard to low earners and you
mentioned one thing tank you know that
also other think tanks including the one
that you mentioned but the independent
institute of fiscal studies for example
has specifically described what we did
on national insurance thresholds as is
the best way through the tax system to
help those on low incomes and middle
incomes because i think the increase in
national insurance thresholds yet that
we put in place yesterday which will
come into effect in july is particularly
well targeted to help those on lower
middle incomes it will provide a tax cut
for 30 million workers and it's worth
for a typical employee about 330 pounds
a year so it does demonstrate we're on
the side of hard-working british people
that's what this government is about and
that's what i'm delivering the ifs may
suggest that you may be slightly
representing them i have a quote from
their director paul johnson yesterday
says what really stands out today is
what's missing he has done nothing more
for those dependent on benefits the very
poorest beside a small amount of extra
cash for local authorities their
benefits will rise by just 3.1 percent
for the coming financial year the cost
of living could well well rise by 10 so
the ifs are not
wholeheartedly welcoming what you
announced yesterday has to be said let's
look at that picture of you filling up
your car um you're looking very jolly
it's a gorgeous sunny day yesterday
wasn't it um
most people when they fill up their car
these days
watch the pounds going up going up going
up it struck me that you weren't even
looking at how much it costs to fill up
your car do you feel it up very often
well actually i was having a
conversation with a person uh that i was
talking to at the same time that's
filling it up and we and we were filling
it up and i was keeping an eye on the
pounds and actually it was about 30
pounds and one pence i didn't quite get
to finish it in the right place so yes i
was keeping an eye on it but i think you
you were just having a conversation
about filling up you were just you were
just
that's what was required but you i mean
one second ago you were saying that all
fuel doing something on fuel duty isn't
particularly valuable and and now we're
having conversations saying that it is i
think actually it is it's the biggest
ever car i'm not saying that pure duty
isn't valuable
and i think and i think it will it will
make a difference to people i mean i
might you know my wife and i have
volkswagen golf and actually she's
filled it up as i was saying the other
week and and it is it is going up of
course we know it's going up and that's
why we took action uh yesterday to to
try and make a difference there were the
biggest ever cut in fuel duty that we've
seen at five pennsylvania
and i'm really glad actually to see
retailers passing that on very quickly
and you know i hope that that happens
across the industry something i called
for yesterday and i see i think asda and
sainsbury's in particular were quick out
of the block saying that they were doing
that and i'm i'm grateful to them for
doing that so that your viewers we can
all benefit from that fuel duty cut as
quickly as possible
but there are those who who will will
look at you and say that that you aren't
really in touch with real people's lives
i mean you've had a very lucky and
privileged life and i know you've talked
about the sacrifices your parents made
to send you to an excellent school
um but i would suggest that you've never
had to worry about making a fiver last
till the end of the week
and there are a lot of people who who
are looking at what was announced
yesterday and we're talking to one of
them just after eight clark i met a man
called barry who's a carer for for two
children who have got health issues his
wife's a care worker and there was
nothing there yesterday they say for
them that will make their lives any
easier and they're looking at the with
horror at the idea that inflation could
go up to as much as 10 percent
well you know this has been put to me
many times and what i say is judge me by
my actions i think people can see how
i've acted over the last couple of years
as our country went through a very
difficult period and i think i
demonstrated that i am standing by
british people when we go through
difficult things i introduce things like
furlough i help this country get through
a pandemic and partly because of the
actions that i took the economy is in a
much stronger place than anyone expected
now with more people on payroll than we
have before the pandemic unemployment
back down to the record low levels we
saw before the crisis that doesn't
happen by accident that happens because
of the policies that we put in place and
it's because of that that we can now
help people to weather some of the
challenges ahead accepting of course as
i've said we can't solve every problem i
wish i could and that's the toughest
part of this job not being able to do
everything that people want you to do
but where i can make a difference of
course that's what i'm doing and again
you know you talk about barry and his
family obviously you can't get into
everyone's individual circumstances but
i i do think families will benefit from
the fuel duty cut we announced yesterday
because many people are reliant on their
cars that will help
millions of people tens of millions of
people will benefit from the increase in
national insurance thresholds that's
going to save people 330 pounds a year
they'll benefit from the increase in the
national living wage they'll benefit
from the increased generosity of the
universal credit taper they'll benefit
from the extra money that we're giving
councils to help those most in need and
they will benefit from the income tax
cut that's coming down the line so look
there's a range of things we're doing
all of which demonstrate we are on the
side of hard-working british families
and that's what we will continue to do
as you say well the prime minister has
just uh made a statement apparently he
said we can do more to stop putin from
using his gold reserves what should we
be doing
i'd say look i i'm not sure the context
of exactly what the prime minister has
said that i'm talking to you but what i
would say is you know he's taken a lead
and deserves enormous credit for
galvanizing international opinion to
deliver a strong message he must have
asked your opinion as the chancellor
about the gold reserves
yeah well there's lots of things we're
doing about the central bank and i've
seen that's what he's what he's talking
about and we've taken a leading role in
sanctioning russia particularly economic
and financial sanctions i outlined those
yesterday in parliament they are having
an impact and people should feel
reassured that what we are doing is
having an impact the russian ruble has
plummeted to record lows the moscow
stock exchange has been essentially
closed for a month and the russian
central bank has had to double interest
rates to 20 in russia so all the various
things we're doing uh are having an
impact and as the prime minister said we
will continue to maintain pressure on
russia
you you mentioned that and you mentioned
the pressure on russia um
it's been reported uh that you've got
family links to russia that your wife
apparently has a stake in the indian i.t
consultancy firm infosys um they operate
in moscow they have an office there they
have a delivery office there they've got
a connection to the alpha bank in moscow
are you giving advice to others that
you're you're not following in your own
home
that's not as i i'm an elected
politician and i'm here to talk to you
about what i'm responsible for uh my
wife is not
she is not but but equally if you you
know as a country we are asking
taxpayers to fund the uk's support for
ukraine we're asking people in the uk to
give their homes up to ukrainian
refugees
whereas it appears your family
potentially could be benefiting from
putin's regime
no i i really i don't think that's the
case and as i said the the operations of
all companies are up to them
we've we've put in place significant
sanctions and all the companies that
we're responsible for are following
those as they rightly should sending a
very strong message
to putin's aggression
do you know if infosys is
i have i have absolutely no idea because
i have nothing to do with that company
okay
um
in terms of of what the prime minister
is saying he is saying that we could be
doing more to stop putin what would you
like to see the british government doing
more
to stop putin and and where will that
money come from we've talked about a new
support package for ukrainian forces six
thousand more anti-tank missiles is this
gonna come from our existing defense
budget
also we we knew that russia was a
particular threat to our security uh
because in the something called the
integrated review which was done a
little while ago it was named very
specifically as a big threat and that's
why we increased our defense budget by
record amounts 24 billion pounds over
the four-year period that's the biggest
increase in defence spending since the
end of the cold war in reflection of the
new threats that we face and it's
because of that extra investment in
defense that we're able to provide
support to our allies like ukraine at
this difficult time and we know that
that is making a difference to their
ability to withstand russian aggression
and i hope people are proud of the
contribution that the british state and
armed forces are playing
chancellor richie sunak thank you very
much for joining us sarah appreciate
your time
thank you thank you
well that chancellor's statement
yesterday has not gone down that well in
the papers the metro suggests that the
chancellor hasn't taken account of
inflation lower living standards and
higher tax burdens in his spring
statement their headline
no heat to eat
the eye says it's the biggest hit to
living standards since rationing was in
force they have a striking graph to go
with it
normally a staunch supporter of the
tories the express is highly critical
referencing forgotten millions asking
what about us
but the mail is more supportive asking
mr sunak to cut taxes even further
well if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to this
morning's sky news daily podcast today
rob powell explores what the spring
statement means for all of us with our
business correspondent helen anne smith
and financial secretary to the treasury
lucy fraser you can subscribe to the
daily wherever you get your podcasts
still to come on the show world leaders
are meeting in brussels for an
extraordinary nato summit on the crisis
in ukraine we'll hear from a former head
of policy planning at the alliance
and a month on from russia's invasion
we'll hear from one of the millions of
ukrainians forced to flee their homes
now one of russia's most senior
diplomats has told sky news that moscow
could press the nuclear button if nato
provokes it dmitry polyanaski was
talking to our u.s correspondent martha
kellner from inside russia's mission to
the united nations in new york
this is one of very few places left in
new york where this man would still be
welcome it's here at the russian mission
to the un where its leading diplomats
write their speeches where they work out
how on earth to defend the indefensible
vladimir putin's personal spokesperson
said that russia retains the right to
use nuclear weapons and to defend the
country whatever that may be from
whatever inventory if russia is provoked
by nato if russia is attacked by nato i
don't know
so we are we are nuclear power
why not you think that's a legitimate
thing to be saying though i don't think
it's the right thing to be seeing but
though it's not the right thing to
to threaten russia and to try to
interfere so
when you're dealing with the nuclear
power of course you have to calculate
all the possible outcomes of of your
behavior that's what i'm going to say
but is russia committing more crimes in
ukraine i don't think we're committing
war crimes in ukraine of course it's not
up to me to to assess uh i'm not there
you're not there you're looking at the
videos you're looking at the
the uh many videos who are considered to
be fake news are you saying that the
civilian
homes playgrounds hospitals theaters
have not been targeted by russia
they were not targeted
and you know it's very well we said from
the very beginning
that our military is not the threat for
civilian population ukraine can i show
you what the u.s believes is evidence of
war crimes these are pictures taken by
our colleagues
associated press independent news site
these are apartments
on fire in mario paul hit by russian
missiles uh how do you know it's russian
missiles
because there is a cell phone is your
suggestion that the ukrainians
apparently i will tell you i will tell
you
it can it can it can easily come from
ukraine from the center of the city it
happened in kharkov it happened in
mariupol because they have their own
missile
launchers and a lot of cases that i know
are reported from ukrainian missiles
themselves ambassador with respect i
think that's preposterous like the idea
that this man of this amount of
destruction i think is quite logical
it's not preposterous
mr polyansky may not believe russia is
guilty of war crimes but the u.s says
they are the international criminal
court will ultimately decide but with
every wild claim being made by its
diplomats russia becomes increasingly
isolated on the world stage martha
kellner sky news new york
in afghanistan schoolgirls were left in
tears when the taliban broke a promise
to let them go back to the classroom
many girls across the country were just
minutes away from starting their first
classes when they were told that they
had to leave among them was 16 year old
khadijah who says her future is ruined
it was like a day of mourning and it was
a very sad day it was like losing a
loved one everyone was crying the girls
were hugging and crying and saying
goodbye
i wanted to be a doctor even though i
knew it would be difficult i like
doctors white coats but now i can't do
anything my future is ruined
in the last hour south korea's military
is reporting north korea has fired a
long-range intercontinental ballistic
missile in their latest test it's
believed to be their 12th missile launch
this year and will be their first launch
since a missile reportedly exploded
mid-air last week
let's get a look at the weather now
or the next few days we'll stay mainly
settled with plenty of sunshine but air
pollution levels will be locally very
high mostly sunny but chilly now with an
extensive ground frost in the
countryside and fog patches in the east
the west of ireland northern ireland and
western scotland are cloudier and milder
with a few showers and some hill and
coastal fog
you are watching sky news coming up
spring has definitely arrived at
blenheim palace with the birth of these
new lambs but the famous country country
house where winston churchill was born
has warned the dog owners visiting the
site must keep their pets on a lead to
protect newborns
other great pictures from the papers
today a resting place fit for a king
this giant 37-ton marble memorial honors
willie collins a bare-knuckle boxer from
sheffield he died in 2020 the monument
features life-size statues led lights
and a solar-powered jukebox
playing collins favorite song
but there's a dispute about whether the
correct permission was granted
and sheffield city council say they're
now in contact with the family over
changes to the site i hope they're going
to say there's a dispute over what his
favorite song was
now world leaders in brussels one month
on since russia's invasion in ukraine
coming up we'll hear from fabrice
pottier the former head of policy
planning at nato
[Music]
[Music]
you're watching sky news our top stories
this morning western leaders are meeting
for an extraordinary nato summit in
brussels the prime minister has said
this morning that the uk will provide
more military support to ukraine
as the war enters its second month
president zielenski calls for global
protests in support of ukraine
and the chancellor rushi sunaka has told
sky news that he can't help everyone but
insist that the government is targeting
support
at those who need it the most
well the chancellor russia cena has
dismissed criticism of the spring
statement that has been in some of the
newspapers today uh let's talk to our
correspondent tamara cohen who is here
with me what what do you think was
significant about what he said in terms
of the reaction because it hasn't been
positive in a lot of the papers has it
no the papers have been quite negative
about it either on the idea that he
hasn't cut taxes enough to help people
with what the official forecaster says
is the biggest squeeze on living
standards since the 1950s this is a
massive challenge has he risen to the
scale of it some say he hasn't cut taxes
enough some say he hasn't provided
enough support to those on the lowest
incomes to carry them through the next
few months and while what he announced
on fuel duty and on the national
insurance changes which will mean a lot
fewer people will pay that tax rise that
comes in at the beginning of april and
it says this is billions of pounds worth
of support but the chancellor had an
extra 50 billion to play with from
higher tax revenues than expected so the
idea that he sort of kept some back is
already talking about income tax cuts in
two years time the chancellor was very
defensive saying look i can't help every
single person we've had an unprecedented
pandemic but people should have enough
to get get by i thought when you put to
him the case of somebody who's on a
fixed income on benefits will not have
any help with massively rising bills he
said oh they may benefit from the fuel
duty cut i think that's the sort of
criticism that is coming the
chancellor's way at the moment
is it enough and a lot of very senior
conservatives are saying privately we
think he'll have to step in again either
in the october budget or even before
well especially as a lot of poor people
just don't drive cars do they we also
asked him about russia the prime
minister saying more needs to be done to
stop vladimir putin today
indeed and i thought he was very uh
defensive there rishi sinak's wife
akshata is very wealthy her father
founded an indian i.t company and she
owns a stake in it and the accusation
being made in some reports is that this
company is still operating in russia it
has an office in moscow it is using
russian banks which is not the message
that the government has been giving out
to businesses in this country which is
that they should try to sever their
links with russia as much as possible to
punish vladimir putin for the war in
ukraine and when you put that to the
chancellor rishi sunak he did not want
to get into what the company's
activities were this is what he said
i i'm an elected politician and i'm here
to talk to you about what i'm
responsible for my wife is not
she is not but but equally if you you
know as a country we are asking
taxpayers to fund the uk's support for
ukraine we are asking people in the uk
to give their homes up to ukrainian
refugees
whereas it appears your family
potentially could be benefiting from
putin's regime
no i i really i don't think that's the
case and as i said the the operations of
all companies are up to them
we've put in place significant sanctions
and all the companies that we are
responsible for are following those as
they rightly should sending a very
strong message uh to putin's aggression
i think the chancellor may well face
more questions about this subject he's
an ambitious politician when it looked
like boris johnson was in trouble over
partygate there was speculation he could
take over as prime minister quite soon
so questions about his own finances and
his own family's links are going to be
coming at him but the chancellor very
defensive over that and over his budget
which is already being picked apart
because while he talked about tax cuts
of course as you put to him the overall
tax burden is higher than it has been
for decades it has indeed tomorrow
thanks very much
well despite the chancellor's claims
that he is cutting taxes there are
claims that the government by the
government's own financial watchdog that
incomes are facing their biggest hit
since the 1950s our correspondent ed
conway has been picking through some of
those figures from yesterday
this was supposed to just be an update
but in practice there were lots
of new policies and new figures and
particularly striking ones underlining
the state of what we are going to be
going through over the next uh few
months this shows you household
disposable income this is a chart that
just was out from the office budget
responsibility anything above the line
shows we are getting better off and
we're going all the way back now to 1956
and you can see that most of these bars
through the years from the 50s to the
60s to the 70s and 80s and 90s are above
the line we're getting better off and
there's the financial crisis a few years
where it was below the line but just
look at this red bar that's the year
we're going into
now and that bar
is the lowest it has ever been the
biggest fall in our real household
disposable income that we've seen in
statistical record that is what we are
confronting at the moment that's the
cost of living crisis
and the chancellor has managed to make
that bar a little bit less deep than it
would otherwise have been but
nonetheless it is still going to be very
tough indeed how has he made it less
deep well it comes down to money going
out of the treasury how much money is
going on we can see each year if we look
at the total policies and the impacts
you can see there was money going into
the treasury uh in the year that we're
in at the moment but next year a bit of
money going out actually quite a lot of
money 8.4 billion pounds and then
smaller amounts in the future years it's
worth us just breaking down that money
that is going out because that's what
we're talking about here all of these
policies uh that have been announced by
the chancellor and when it comes to
breaking it down there are some
interesting things in fact on top of the
money that's going out and we'll look at
that in a second there was a bit of
extra money coming in student loans
because of a change in the way that
they're calculated students will end up
paying more money in the coming years
and that's banks by the treasury but
then you've got that cash going out
that's helping to finance that change in
the national insurance threshold extra 3
000 pounds that you kind of don't have
to pay national insurance on quite a lot
of money fuel duty as well 2.4 billion
pounds not the biggest chunk but
nonetheless pretty big and then that
that's the energy bills uh package that
we had just uh not too long ago from the
chancellor nine billion pounds just over
nine billion pounds but here's the thing
he could have spent more and that's the
big question mark do we see him come
back later when that cost of living
crisis starts to bear down on everyone
and spend a little bit more money the
final thing that's worth saying there
was that tax plan from the chancellor a
document underlining how much he wants
to get those taxes down but here's a
chart that wasn't in it this is the tax
burden taxes as a percentage of gdp just
how heavily taxed we are as an economy
again going all the way back through to
history to the post-war period and have
a look at this line it's relatively low
and it kind of hangs around this area
kind of 30s 33 or so percent
but even when income tax has been cut by
a penny which he plans to do towards the
end of this parliament it's still this
line gonna be the highest it's been
since
1949 underlining the fact that though he
wants to be seen as a tax cutting
chancellor the statistics tell a very
different story indeed so those are some
of the data from this big moment for the
chancellor far bigger than most people
expected it was supposed to just be a
spring statement it felt actually a bit
more like a budget
conway there the prime minister's on his
way to brussels is going to be talking
to nato and eu leaders i think he's
talking to journalists on the plane
he is saying that he is going to
increase the pressure on vladimir putin
uh other lines coming out of that
conversation he says that putin has
already crossed a red line and that
point but i also put to rishi soon act
that we can do more to stop putin from
using his gold
reserves and he reiterated the fact that
he talks to president zielinski
regularly he says he's going to be
seeing him shortly as well and he also
added that he believes it's right that
president putin should appear before the
international criminal court which is
something that lots of different human
rights groups have called for
in ukraine the siege of mario paul has
trapped tens of thousands of people
without food water or medicine residents
are struggling to survive under constant
russian bombardment our correspondent
sally lockwood spoke to one mum who
managed to escape
the city of mariopol is almost totally
destroyed
in its ashes are at least a hundred
thousand people trapped and trying to
stay alive
but it's feared there could be far more
than that
the city is surrounded and the bombs
drop day and night
escaping from here on foot seems
unfathomable
but we've met one family who did
we watched as we went to the checkpoint
cars were shot there
there was an old man and a woman in the
car they were shot next to each other
and for so many days they just were in a
car nobody picked their
we walked down bodies street and there
was an apocalypse around us it was scary
there it felt we were in a horror movie
as we walked away from the city we saw
broken tanks buses and unexploded
composure is astounding
natalia and her son bogdan have made it
to the west of ukraine with the help of
strangers
but when they first escaped mario paul
four days ago they refused an offer by
russian forces to take them to russia
there is so much trauma and no trust
they showed us this video of their
bombed home
the shells started to hit they flew into
the yard broke down on balcony a man
went out on the balcony to smoke and the
balcony was hit by a shell he died
then more a bomb also flew into the
neighbor's house the house burned down
completely we decided to move from our
house to the next one and when we
reached it strong explosion started we
jumped into the entrance a bomb flew
into our car and exploded
they found themselves sheltering in a
basement for almost a month but with
enough food for just a few days
they had money in bank cards but there
was nothing to buy
there were problems with food because
everyone thought it would only be for a
few days and then we sat in a basement
and realized that we were there for 22
days
it was almost a month
we had a spoonful of porridge very
little everyone lost weight
their courage has carried them so far
but so many of their friends remain
trapped in mario pole and what that
means for them is a terrifying prospect
but for this family they no longer feel
safe in ukraine
poland is the next stop with no plan
beyond survival
sally lockwood sky news la viv in
western ukraine
well another one of the millions who've
been displaced is the journalist
anastasia nadula who fled kiev her
husband stayed behind anastasia
and stalia good to talk to you thank you
very much um what is the latest
in your life where are you now how are
you coping
hi hi it's very nice to meet you and see
you i'm currently in the alve region
uh quite close to leaf itself um i had
to flick it because of the content
constant
bombings there
and constant danger there um yeah
currently this region is more or less
fine more or less safe
but there is a huge influx of internal
immigrants in here
and yeah the region is just trying to
cope with everything um but i decided to
stay in ukraine i decided not to leave
my country
but you have though i had to leave your
hometown of kiev and you've left your
husband behind how's he managing
uh
we managed to meet just for a couple of
days he came here to see me and then
left again he's been engaged in active
volunteering work all around ukraine
he's helping our army a lot as well as
working as a journalist to highlight
what's happening in the country
and yeah he travels a lot around ukraine
and
sometimes he's in kiev as well and the
atmosphere there and the level of danger
there is still unacceptable to return
people still are living there under
constant air raids bombings etc so his
aim for now is just to help our
our army
our defenders as much as possible and
he's engaged in that work
what is he able to tell you about the
humanitarian corridors and whether or
not people are
trying and succeeding to get out safely
unfortunately humanitarian corridors
which are agreed with russian army
aren't
are not
are not entirely safe i would say that
they are not safe at all especially the
human characters from marupo are being
constantly attacked and bombarded by
russian army
so the hardest situations currently are
in marupal and in cherny heath people
from there they just cannot leave the
city um some of the people i know my
friends had to leave mariupol by feet
because it's super dangerous to live it
by car because russian army constantly
attacks it and humanitarian characters
it's just a matter of how lucky you are
you might be successful to use it safely
or you
might might get shot so that's a huge
problem that it's impossible to agree
with the russian army on real
humanitarian careers from the cities
that are struggling the most
and what about the the other way in
people getting aid into those places are
bits of aid able to get in
excuse me good to repeat please
yeah what about humanitarian aid we know
that that has been a real problem
getting anything into places like mario
paul although are there any routes open
at all that you're aware of
no un unfortunately we know that for
sure that russian army doesn't let a
humanitarian corrupt
humanitarian aid into the cities for
instance i have a friend in a city
called berdank's it connects to her son
and you rarely hear about it in the news
but there is no food no medicine nothing
and russian army doesn't let
humanitarian aid to get into the city
and i'm not even talking of mariupol
humanitarian aid red cross
not a single organization can get there
because their aim is to
i don't know for our people for arts
villains to struggle i guess as much as
possible
so that's a huge problem
what is your message to international
leaders g7 and nato are meeting today in
brussels uh our prime minister here in
the uk says more needs to be done to
stop president putin
what would you like to see the rest of
the world do
first of all i will i think all
ukrainians are really grateful
especially to the uk for all for all the
help and all the support that we are
getting especially from your prime
minister boris johnson and secondly
we would be super grateful for more
heavy
weapons
if we would get more heavy weapons we
would be able to close sky by ourselves
and we would be able to
finish this work with our victory
much much faster and of course the third
aspect is sanctions we need even more
sanctions more pressure to put on russia
to put on their economy so ordinary
russians
would uh would realize what actually is
really happening the real war is
happening in the center of europe right
now and ukrainians are defending their
values of democracy of freedom with
their blood
thousands of people are dying not only
army civilians children
women
we would be super grateful
indeed and in terms of that
people in russia understanding what is
going on um we know that that people who
have got family in russia have tried
talking to them from ukraine and tried
saying this is the situation this is
what happened is happening on the ground
in ukraine and they are still being met
with disbelief inside russia do you know
people inside russia have you been able
to talk to them about what is actually
happening in ukraine
i have a lot of friends from all over
from all over the world and russia as
well
i have
i know lots of people from russia i
managed to talk to them but almost all
people who actually live right now in
russia don't believe that there is a
real war happening in ukraine they think
that there is especially military
operation the propaganda is so strong
i don't know in the first days of war i
was trying to persuade them right now i
just feel that it's impossible to beat
this propaganda only russians that
currently live abroad in european
countries they fully realize what's
what's happening but those in the russia
only a few few people actually
understand
the level
of fascism
that's happening right now in ukraine
from russia
so that's very hard the propaganda is
super strong there
anesthesia nedula a journalist in
ukraine really good to talk to you stay
safe and i hope your husband stays safe
as well thank you thank you thank you
you're watching sky news breakfast
coming up we'll have a report from
jamaica where prince william has
expressed his sorrow over slavery but
stop short of the apology demanded by
activists
[Music]
prince william has expressed his
profound sorrow for slavery but stopped
short of the apology demanded by
activists in jamaica a warning this
report does contain flashing images from
the start sky's royal correspondent ren
and mills is following the couple on
their caribbean tour
[Music]
anticipation was high as the duke and
duchess of cambridge arrived at the
appropriately named king's house
1953 was when the queen first came here
when jamaica was still a british colony
now all eyes on her grandson under
pressure to apologize for the painful
past
i strongly agree with my father the
prince of wales who said in barbados
last year
that the appalling atrocity of slavery
forever stains our history
i want to express my profound sorrow
slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened
while the pain runs deep
jamaica continues to forge its future
with determination
courage
and fortitude
father shawn was one of those who wrote
an open letter asking william to
acknowledge the royal family's role in
the slave trade he was left disappointed
it is always disappointing
when
responsibility is not taken
for certain actions and certainly this
is not just any action it's crimes
against humanity
earlier in the day in a surprisingly
blunt meeting in front of the cameras
prime minister andrew holness had
already alluded to the protests
we are moving on
and we intend to
attain
in short order development goals
and focuses our true ambitions investing
as an independent
developed prosperous
culture his ambitions also clear that
jamaica should cut ties with the royal
family
the royals don't think the republic
debate is one for them but there is no
way that prince william could ignore the
issue of slavery it was always unlikely
that he was going to go further than his
father even though there will be those
disappointed he didn't mention
reparations but in a sign of how much
his words did matter to him he was keen
there were no leaks and they were heard
from him first
william and kate have been left in no
doubt they are forming a new kind of
relationship with jamaica this tour was
never going to solve all of the issues
at play but it has amplified the voices
of those demanding change rhiannon mills
sky news in kingston jamaica
[Music]
you're watching sky news coming up we're
going to have the latest from brussels
as eu and nato leaders meet to discuss
what more can be done to stop the war in
ukraine
[Music]
you